Poor shit.
Seals, what drives them?
They always have a plan.
And if the plan goes to shit, guess what they have?
Not a good plan.
So in a game like this, where you've got this and you're striking and you're coming down,
you've got to get across, you've got a goal, you've got an objective, you have a plan.
Hey listen, if it comes to me, I'm going to pass it to you, I'm going to give it to him.
I'm all too, but hey, run towards the orange shorts
because I think there's a little bit of a gap there.
Plan.
It could be as, on a rugby field, when you take your girlfriend out for a fucking night out,
there's a plan, isn't there?
Because if there isn't, there's no fucking hoochie-coochie after the movie.
I'm putting that foot in the field.
Have a plan.
Okay, last one.
Let's get a duck.
Let's have...
Get it, Frank.
I'll put him over here.
Can I clear up there for that one?
Yeah.
Here, Coy, let me get a shot of you.
Did you have a perk on, or what?
Yeah, you did.
Right here.
Put a player here, one here, one here, one there, and on that yellow turn.
That's the thumbnail.
So, four players on each turn here, and then four players on the other side.
And that's it.